live Duda in second place in the
tournament and here we go yeah it's a
queen's Pawn opening uh Duda usually
opening with his kingsbourne so maybe a
small surprise there for gokash but we
are heading into maybe one of the main
positions here with uh okay a Queen's
Gambit declined
and the Catalan so dudo going for this
really trendy topical approach everyone
seems to be playing the Catalan nowadays
it's kind of a mix between strategy and
dynamism in these types of openings how
will kokesh react black has a bunch of
solid ways also a bunch of ambitious
ways to meet the Catalan but uh I'm sure
you've seen this before I'm sure he's
got a line or two up his sleeve he just
needs to choose which one
doodle with a small surprise
I don't know have you guys seen him play
the Catalan before I I certainly can't
remember can't recall
and uh okay a check is met by the bishop
blocking Black's main move here is to
retreat the black dark Square Bishop uh
there's a couple of squares you can
choose but there we go it Retreats back
to its main Square
and after the both King's Castle I'm
assuming they're just going to do the
same we do get this kind of standoff
where still little pieces on the board
white wants to at some point occupy the
center white needs to bring the rest of
his pieces into the game but black is
Rock Solid and it's hard to break down
black structure
uh the triangle formation in the middle
of the board as we call it with black
that pawn structure just uh very hard to
break uh White's Queen finding a
slightly better Square reminds me of
when I played uh a sport that was very
big in Norway but not many other
countries hamble and defending we would
always be told to to have this triangle
formation to defend and it's the
triangle about defending or attacking in
chess it's about defending to begin with
but it also has counter-attacking
possibilities there because I mean black
has a lot of flexibility with this
little triangle formation because either
of those backward pawns can move forward
so that's why it's flexible and uh here
we see gukash also seizing some space on
the left side of the board but the issue
for him is all about the light squared
bishop and he has to get it out he has
to give it a roll
yeah blacks Bishop Black's a C8 Bishop
is just a terrible piece it's a bit like
a French defense well that's the problem
child
and uh this last move this Pawn push
I've seen Magnus play it several times
uh White here has a bunch of ways to
react Duda at some point he'll try and
get his Queen side night out that night
that's sitting at home doing nothing
much experience on this side of the
board uh zero
never had this position I've seen it of
course plenty of times I've commentated
on it a fair bunch of times never had it
just not my cup of tea I'm afraid from
either side I would get squeezed with
black and uh probably be a little bit
too uh ambitious with white so just yeah
and this is fairly standard stuff but
allowing this apron to run down the
board I don't recall that being it's a
theory is it yeah yeah okay
sorry wait no no no I'm I'm I'm looking
forward to hearing so this has been
played in a bunch of top games yeah a
bunch of top games uh we have uh video
trying this with the white pieces
against Liam Lee we have another strong
Russian Grandmaster Nikita Richard gov
against themchenko uh Fabiana Carano
played this with the black pieces
against the wojosec uh one of
a Polish player who actually has played
on the tour a few times so yeah
definitely very well known
yeah if voter checks played that
position maybe dude is aware um those
two are very close and those two polish
players and uh okay Duda maybe with a
bit less experience in this type of
position than some of his kind of elite
counterparts
maybe he'll spend a bit of time here
trying to be creative trying to decide
what to do with white and eventually he
does stop the further advance of that
black apron black was gaining a lot of
space with this Rook there for his Rook
there so that Advance has been blocked
strategically long term this could be an
ugly porn move just because there are
some holes now on White's Queen side
white will struggle to push the pawn
next to this the white deep one it was
just going to get captured so who have
to come up with other plans
I'm gonna sneeze
sorry guys I'll hold that one back and
meanwhile gokesh plays a bit of a
waiting game just takes control
um awesome squares gives the black king
an escape Square for later
it's very cagey again just both players
just mocking up the territory
controlling squares yet to really
initiate any direct confrontation but
this pawn move is rare I mean I was
taking a look at the database it's much
more common for black to jump forward
with the knight uh playing uh this
little poor move it seems to me perhaps
slightly on the passive side but then
again you know black really hasn't done
anything too wrong it's just a very
solid position
and uh whilst they're playing well we
can read a few tweets and uh tapes new
bay and says that they finally turned 18
yesterday so someone who generally had a
birthday so uploading my selfie today
along with enjoying the meltwater
Champions Chester aim chess rapid
tournament and uh giving us some thanks
for our commentary so happy birthday
happy belated birthday tapes new and uh
there we see the queen develop to the
edge of the board and then Newton 29
says that sends us Greetings From the
Black Forest
says I would be very happy if you would
analyze the games in a few weeks I will
play my first over-the-board tournament
and it will help me a lot
so this is actually a common common
thing that we've seen a lot of people
taking up the game
um because of the pandemic playing it
online and they want to make that
transition into over the board chess and
everyone's kind of wondering like how to
do this
hmm
hopefully we'll get a chance to offer
some advice to as many players as
possible yeah meanwhile this position's
still very tense this last move very
natural for black just defending the a
pawn
screen on a decent Square
would you be tempted to launch Ford in
the center here Lawrence just guess
black is threatening to win a pawn yeah
so I mean it's definitely a move you
have to consider pawns before
um I wonder if you can play other music
maybe Knight D2 immediately is also is
it ridiculous to play this move I mean
you run into G5 maybe is it awkward
to track down this bishop yeah Bishop
b39 G4
could be a little bit awkward so yeah
why does to be a bit a bit precise here
um
does the move Bishop deep to make any
sense I guess it doesn't really
indirectly hitting the queen I guess the
queen has to move
yeah
yeah this Bishop's always a problem in
these yeah in these systems right
because as you said on the Square is a
bit vulnerable to pawns sometimes to
nights okay he doesn't want to hang
around uh this is very much in Duda
Style just to be direct
forward in the center white has this
great Trio now but one of them is likely
to be eliminated
I guess the most ambitious is for black
to be greedy and take a pawn
and uh this actual position has occurred
once before against uh two grand Masters
Richard Gough and damchenko and black
did not dare to grab the Free Pawn
that's up for grabs instead they
captured the pawn in the middle and uh
retrieved a passive position and duly
lost yeah this type of position you
mentioned the word passive your vanco
it's because white has a nice Pawn
Center black has these two pawns which
aren't really going to push forward
anytime soon black also has this bishop
that's entombed uh stuck at home no real
life for that Bishop in the near future
instead okay kakesh he's very ambitious
he doesn't want to be passive of course
so he does get greedy and grab a pawn
he's got something to suffer for at
least something to hold on to and and do
to immediately react by threatening that
pawn also possibly hinting at breaking
up in the center
White's Queen is on the same line as an
undefender Bishop so if the Center opens
up that could be a factor
what do you guys do now this bonus
Under Fire we don't really want to lose
it right defend it
hold on to that one with all our might
um yeah either do I think I would do it
with a pawn with the pawn I guess you
could also do the queen uh yeah oops
defend it that way but the only thing
I'd be worried about and I would be
scared about defending that uh the C4
Pawn with another Pawn is uh okay yeah
there's maybe a queen one is better but
yeah because I'm really afraid and it's
in this type of position though it's
very thematic for white to blast open
the Santa
and that could be
problems yeah 99 problems right pan
against this bishop suddenly this bishop
is coming to life and it's on the same
diagonal as the black Rook
actually I'm kind of surprised we don't
see dude or play more of these catalans
because these kind of Pawn sack
positions are very much aligned with his
style yeah you know he's a very very
good player with the initiative and uh
would like to see him play more of this
actually go cash is he's got a tricky
spot now because the next move is going
to actually determine a lot of things in
this game
yeah if he can't hold on to his Pawn
he's just worse as black and not much to
excited about for gokash I think you're
right Lawrence is right up his street
Duda he loves these imbalance structures
or imbalanced kind of material
um you know material situations it's
that makes sense he's been playing 184
for most of his career he might as well
Branch out right
yeah yeah all right he's the spice of
life with openings yeah I agree
but it takes so much courage to change
from an old favorite hey
I don't know well in chess you gotta
don't experiment with everything you end
up with a very one-dimensional style or
very very predictable there's really
only one player in the in the in the
elite who who has done that okay it
sticks with the same MBL yeah I mean mvl
has had the same opening pretty much
since he was in short pants and uh uh
you know he's he's been playing the the
the groomfeld and the night of literally
since the first time I've ever met him
now he knows these openings inside out
but he's very predictable yeah
um and
but he's a very rare exception because
still he plays them and still most
players can't get something against
these systems but
you have to know these openings
literally been playing them for 20 years
if you're gonna If You're Gonna Play
like that so having an a broader
repertoire at top level is absolutely
absolutely essential and all of these
players really if you think about it in
this tournament can play pretty much
yeah I have anything for both yeah at
what level would you say it's okay just
to have a very fixed opening level like
what race what kind of rating would you
say it's it's interesting because
actually I get this question from a lot
of my students a lot of my students say
well I've I've seen this course or this
video on this opening that looks
interesting I've seen this video on that
and I said you know you're not really in
a position where you can just try and
learn all of these different systems
better just to try and master one I
would say when you start getting really
Advanced that's when you can start
branching out and I'm talking about over
2200 I don't think you need to learn
more than one system seriously if you're
1800 it's just what you could do I one
of my students shout out Joel if if
you're watching
um he wanted to have a repertoire as
black where he had a very safe
repertoire so he would have a solid
repertoire and then if he was playing
somebody much much weaker he wanted
something a bit more ambitious so you
could try and find two similar lines
for example playing a caracon or
something one line which is very solid
and then another which is a bit more
ambitious something like that
um
you know but would you agree with that
David oh do you do you really need to
play E4 and D4 if you're 1900 right yeah
um I I agree 2200 2300 yeah sometimes
even higher yeah I think you can get
away with just being very loyalty
openings as long as you're diligent and
learn them as as thoroughly as possible
practice there but I think anyone who
plays chess professionally
I I think I I mean in my opinion at
least they should have which they should
be willing to experiment or they should
be trying to broaden their repertoire as
much as possible because I think
nowadays it's just there's no excuse I
mean you can learn an opening in a day
pretty much
um if you'd play the same opening your
whole life you get hit in the same
opening time and time again your
opponents prepare for you you never ever
get an advantage out the opening and
you're giving yourself a handicap how
did familyl started playing something
different now well he does from time to
time he's not completely strict but I
mean
with white he varies a bit with black
he's tried to experiment but yeah I
don't know just because he's had 20 plus
25 years of built up knowledge in
certain openings he's lacking maybe in
some other areas and it takes a lot of
dedication at the top level to suddenly
change later in life
I recommend trying a bit while you're
younger just to make sure you're happy
with your openings if you are then those
should be the main ones even if you add
stuff later and what's very important
just and we will get back to the game
not much has happened so
um is that you choose openings
not to just learn move by move by move
but to be able to get to positions which
you enjoy playing that you feel
comfortable in that's something else
that people do right exactly so it's
very important to Define your style
early on are you aggressive are you
tactical do you prefer slow games
maneuvering games once you've
established that then you should really
base your opening repertoire around that
that's where a lot of players go wrong
so you know you know a student could be
super solid he like oh I want to play
the uh the wing Gambit and it's like
well hold on a second mate you're you
like solid positions now you want to
give up half your half your pieces
um so make sure you have a clear idea of
what kind of positions you like and then
if you have a coach or advice then base
your opening repertoire around that
style yeah I think that's where a coach
comes in it's not to tell you exactly
what to do it's just to kind of point
you in the right direction just say okay
this one I think would suit you
um for example if you are a solid player
then maybe some Slavs some berlins or
some martial attacks but uh yeah
you definitely need to know yourself
that's key to being a good chess player
and finding an idol maybe then so if you
are a very solid player who should be
your favorite player who should be the
one you
but yeah I mean exactly and not just
find some model players but model games
as well in your favorite opening whether
it's the London system or the wing
Gambit or there's always players of a
certain level who play that opening very
well who studied it played it most of
their life you can basically use their
knowledge and borrow ideas and that's
like a shortcut again to mastering these
openings definitely and meanwhile the
White Knight has jumped into the center
and is attacking the pawn and uh gakash
he's just a centralized a rook
still very transpositioned because white
can actually just recapture the
sacrificed porn and still the question
remains how is black going to make use
of this very poorly situated light
Square Bishop
yeah
um very good question there and maybe
the key question in the position right
now
it's to me at least it's not due to
style to take this Pawn um you're right
Ivanka
yeah I just had a feeling he was going
to do something like this um you're
right this is a decent move that's
probably the move I would play just
because it's my style I don't want to be
material down for too long unless I can
help it and after a couple of Trades
white still has this beautiful Pawn
Center but at the same time black is
traded off the piece uh black could
maybe offered to trade off the queens
and if the Queens disappear white space
Advantage not so important and that is
not who Duda is he wants to play
ambitiously aggressively
pushes the H Pawn up the board and what
do we think is that just kind of
prefacing a further I I think so and and
it's not caveman-like anymore you know
years ago this would just be seen as a
coffee house player uh the likes of
myself uh maybe the ginger GM uh If he
if he doesn't mind me including him in
that group but you know the computers
have basically all confirmed that this
is a good way of playing and they
absolutely love it they love if you
control the center like this you can
expand on the flank look at Black's
pieces the night on B6 the queen on A5
The Rook on A8 all off-site so why can't
I expand on on the king side here now I
don't know if G4 in this exact position
is the correct move maybe you have to
prep it slightly but it wouldn't
surprise me if it's a legal move here
David what do you what do you think
I think again it's due to style I think
he's going to play it and the top
players they seem to make it work right
um they can get away with pushing pawns
um it's definitely the move he wants to
play
um for me I would be asking what else is
there a backup plan is there another
safe option but uh I guess again you can
take this Pawn if you want to play Super
safe is it what Duda wants to do does he
feel comfortable in those types of
situations where a bunch of pieces might
get exchanged does he want to just keep
the tension maybe improve his Bishop
exactly
um but yeah number one thing you
calculate is pushing forward with this
pawn and
you can you can even be you know really
Sly and just play you know I'm thinking
of that famous Alpha Zero game where he
went King H2 it's not the right position
but how ridiculous is a move like King
H2 here just literally prepping Bishop
three Rook G1 G4 yeah and and
Checkmate the guy
yeah makes sense and you're right
Lawrence like just 10 years ago even if
uh if you against me had played a move
like G4 afterwards in the analysis I
would have been like ah you're at it
again what are you doing
um did you really think this would work
and nowadays computers are like yep it's
the best move
so that's how chess evolves and I think
he's going to play it I just have a
feeling whether it's good or not I guess
black here because his Knight is about
to get hit uh he would Retreat and try
to trade off pieces black really needs
to do to do that while he's cramped
while he's struggling for space and the
question here would be whether white can
continue and there I go saying he's
going to go on the attack and no he wins
his Pawn back
topping off pieces Duda particularly
surprised by this I have to say I
thought he was going to play the bishop
move I could see that one being part of
the Arsenal
now the problem now is what you do after
for example the lights come off and the
black queen drops back
it's not really what I want to do as
black but at least if I can get the
Queens off I can say
yes I'm struggling for space but I'm
solid can I play Queen A2 there yeah you
can keep the Queens on
um just be very annoying and say my
queen is actually not bad on A2 yeah she
supports an a further Advance later
maybe
yeah I would be inclined to do this as
white maybe this is what do this
planning as well Black's still
struggling if black ever pushes this
pawn it allows white to step forward in
the center gaining space
flag doesn't push this Pawn what is what
is the plan simply isn't normally the
plan to attack the dark squared bishop
and uh Retreat the Knight again yeah
just get away yeah just high and then go
okay fine I'm happy with the draw go
back I'm threatening to come in again
would still go on the attack eventually
um yeah really interesting decision it's
not what we expected but here we'll go
cash go for the queen Exchange
eight minutes against just under eight
minutes Namaste on the clock
any predictions so far guys
I mean it's a tough one to predict
results wise I think there's just all
you know all three results are very much
in play here depends how optimistic Duda
wants to be if he's going to give go
catch some chances
um but
yeah as I say I I didn't really like
taking on C4 there I felt like you kind
of give away a bit of initiative there
and you'll move Queen A6 I do like that
after Queen A2 you still need to move
there with black still need a plan yeah
just a good opening choice I think from
Duda yeah go cash will be a bit
frustrated if he can't do anything right
now
yeah definitely and uh whilst the
players are thinking and we're like
pondering what's White's best and what's
Black's best uh plan we do have a
question from Abdul Malik who asks us
who was your first strong Grandmaster
that you defeated when you were young so
Lawrence over to you oh goodness
strong Grandmaster hi
um notable grandma said that I'd be it
doesn't have to be a notable just say
your first Grandma I can't even remember
every Grand Master's notable I should
remember the first Grand Master I think
I was about 12 or 13.
um I can't remember his name off the top
of my head
you go first and I'll think about it
David for sure knows um when I was eight
I don't know if this counts it was a
Blitz game it was official tournament I
beat John Nunn um who at the time I mean
he was a child prodigy himself and very
strong Grandmaster I think he used to be
top 20 in the world uh when I was 10 in
a classical over the board game I beat
Colin McNabb and when I was 11 I beat
quite a strong Grandmaster from the
former Soviet Union
um but yeah it was a long time ago world
record the eight and when you were eight
that was the world record right yeah I
think it's the youngest to beat a
Grandmaster in an official uh tournament
it's a great oh it's so cool it was five
plus three the time limited yeah
actually it's one of the best games I've
ever played I look back now I'm like why
aren't I it's good now it was just a
really nice smooth kind of strategic
game and yeah do you still have like uh
do you still have them the note sheet
from that game will you like save from
the best games you play yeah
people my score sheets yeah
I probably shouldn't but I'm a hoarder
so so how many you how many do you have
then if you keep all of them it's in
four figures I think thousands probably
yeah how about you guys
no I don't know what uh score sheets
I've I've lived with far too many uh
Partners too
to hoard such things
um
no uh
that's why we have databases David so
that we don't have to carry around these
students and signatures yeah yeah you've
got nice handwriting though so that
makes a big difference yeah and
meanwhile it seems like Duda has lost
his patience with the waiting game and
has now initiated action in the center
nice yeah yeah the position is going to
be blasted open yeah and interesting
moment to choose because Duda can still
gain some time against the White Queen
the White Queen isn't entirely safe
where she stands
um let's jump in just to show what's
happened uh here I was expecting of
course that Queen trade that we
mentioned
Kakashi is more ambitious he Retreats
his Knight and bang the center is about
to open up
um because of these two threats black
can't block up the center I was gonna
say but he does I was also maybe
expecting the Knight to come and
challenge the queen first but okay he
blocks and hits this bishop The Bishop's
just happy to retreat I'm very surprised
at kakash's choice because now white has
this very strong Pawn in the center if
you ever traded off
either you could replace it with another
Pawn a past Pawn or you would take it
with a knight and your knight is done a
beautiful Outpost
so what is gokash's plan in the current
position
um yeah I don't think it looks
attractive to take this Pawn
what else can you maybe try this idea
again this
maybe be upon sacrifice here if the
Knight attacks the White Queen I'm not
sure white wants to go for this but it
white could for example take this Knight
and then take this Pawn on the edge of
the board
going upon up but at the cost of the
bishop pair so this is one sacrifice go
cash could go for
struggling to see what else to be honest
um very surprised his move actually it
just looks like it helped why I don't
know about you guys but uh
yeah I agree it looks really nice for
white this is kind of what you're told
is the dream in a Catalan opening yeah I
I agree but then again I think uh
must have been feeling quite desperate
or very unhappy with this position to
allow this and instead he jumps I was
just about to say
you found something I well I mean I'm
not checking a computer but my first
instinct here is this drops a piece to
D6 push the pawn right yeah you're right
you have to be a bit clever here but you
push forward and The Rook on C1 right
you sever the connection between the
bishop and the Knight the bishop needs
to protect the knights and if for
example Bishop takes port and you remove
the bishop and here you emerge with uh
two pieces for the black rook and okay
black has another Pawn but uh two pieces
are better than the rook and like you
said Lawrence uh maybe talk us through
this variation if Rook takes yeah so if
Rook takes uh the point is now you can
just go there's a bishop takes C5 and if
Rook takes D1 the key point is you've
got Knight takes D1 uh with the Rook on
C1 now
providing Extra Protection and that is a
piece and
D6 might just end proceedings here yeah
he'll fight on good cash for sure okay
he takes with the bishop but I was just
going to say backward night moves like
in this situation backward Night Moves
that's what cost Magnus in his game
against kakesh they're just so hard to
spot uh it's against human instinct to
retreat tonight and this would have won
a cake for the other variation Bishop
takes porn Rook takes bishop and at the
end okay he takes with the queen
so it's uh yeah a sad material balance
for black two pieces are better than the
rook and pawn right now
yeah this is a miserable position for
black I mean this is
this is a nightmare for a Grandmaster
yeah
yeah you take the minor pieces Over The
Rook here every time yeah the Queens are
off as well and the Kakashi's in a bad
end game The Rook comes in trying to get
active trying to hit this Pawn on B2 I
guess I guess this will just be defended
there we go and The Rook will be evicted
over the next few moves by the bishop
coming back
yeah it's gonna be a slow game now
kakesh he's not a piece down he's not
actually any material down but the
evaluation bar confirms that White's
pieces are so much better than the
BlackRock and this is actually something
that
at the maybe lower levels isn't such a
big factor rook and porn can often fight
against two pieces but not here
not between these guys
black Rook is it trapped
can oh it's nearly trapped it's very
close I don't think he's gonna live on
the second row because it will be
trapped that's why he Retreats it yeah
it would have got trapped this way so he
steps back
and okay now white can
for example bring the king towards the
center just to cover some squares maybe
start improving this bishop
still some work to be done
chances at all you see for a fight back
from kakash I mean there are there are
always chances I mean we've seen people
recover recover from worse positions I
mean
I mean you can see a kind of situation
say if black were to activate the light
squared bishop and maybe set up a pawn
chain on the light squares maybe it's
possible to hold the position
and just I mean I'm just thinking in
defensive terms because I really don't
think black has any right to be
ambitious here because the Rooks are
just not well placed yeah and even if
for example even if white gives you
everything you want even if you get the
double drugs on the D file they're not
coming in they're not doing anything uh
White is always controlling these dark
squares the pawns are stuck eventually
white can even start thinking about
pushing on this side of the board as
well
yeah this is a position that David Howe
dreams of having with why I had a dream
about this position
very good for dinner he does actually
bring the king
all right at least we predicted okay we
were just showing an example but dude is
going for this variation
so cash basically needs to get lucky
like it
does Magnus blundered yeah but I think
he needs more luck here than he did
against Magnus the Magnus position was
always crazy he always had chances even
if he was worse
it's uh this one
you need a big blunder if anything even
bigger than the the one we saw in the
previous game
and okay Duda blocking some pawns with
White's Bishop
remember jonquist of Judah because
Prague is not playing this tournament
Pride currently in second place on the
tour standings Duda will be the player
in second place probably if Anish giri
doesn't win the tournament and Duda he
has to win
almost all of his games to have any
hopes of winning the tour it's getting
very close for minus Carlsen even with
one tournament left to win the meltwater
Champions chess store 2022
dude that he just needs to win a lot of
games yeah I mean it was virtually all
the games right yeah the just the chance
of catching magnus's score and uh well
we see the bishop attack the Rooks so
Rook black really isn't doing so much
here it's just about uh moving the
pieces trying to find some purpose to
them and just waiting to see how white
improves
and whilst the players are thinking well
I just want to share with you two
selfies the first one is actually an art
drawing from Maritza who says honestly I
just want to keep qualifying for
olympiads and play in more tournaments
so I can keep my chess player portraits
and I don't cheat but who do you think
that is I'm Far East yeah it's Jordan
did you cheat no no I didn't
it does look like a very good picture
and okay The Rook moves and Ed Hyde says
I was walking to breakfast yesterday and
these two gentlemen were gracious enough
to have a photo taken made my day and
there we see
and Alejandro well speaking of which
that's probably probably from the U.S
Championship then yep what's been
happening there
have you guys been uh following at all
yeah I haven't actually the first couple
of days what's what's been going on so
Fabiano uh going into today's game which
starts a bit later
um Fabiano is in the lead okay half a
point above Ray Robson okay but those
two have a significant uh lead above the
pack and Ray bobson had a streak and
also Hans Neiman yesterday he won his
game and he said he's ready to make a
comeback okay yeah because all eyes are
on Hans Neiman after all the cheating
allegations he did struggle a little bit
for a few games there but winning
yesterday I can see is now on four and a
half points that is two and a half
points behind Fabiano in Seoul lead
and still four rounds to go in the US
Championship yeah that one's a marathon
13 long classical games wow yeah
yeah and uh I mean while this game is
going down the predicted Parts I guess
nothing uh too drastic happening white
just
getting ready getting organized black
has literally no plan
Max just has to sit and wait and curl up
into a ball later
are you surprised it says plus five for
white I think Bishop H3 might just be
strong at some moment I don't know
exactly when because then the
broadcaster vacate the C file and then
can you just play something as as simple
as Knight D1 uh Knight E3 move the
bishop
win the C6 Pawn
Hit The Rook first okay he doesn't go
this way but you're right just move the
Knight you can go in any direction for
example here then you jump in maybe jump
in yeah it's just I mean even if black
swaps off everything right this is just
hopeless
um utterly hopeless uh the two Bishops
just control the whole board and
eventually white will get ready to maybe
bring his King in this way
um okay black is the one bringing the
king in the game
so this is the current game position and
I think your idea Lawrence yeah yeah
um he just prepped that one so now if
the bishop takes the knights he's not
even going to swap off one pair of rocks
he'll take with his bishop and these two
again far stronger than Black's Rook
yeah simple trust yeah and simple is
often the best and I guess we're going
to see the Knight relocate itself to the
center
and I'm just waiting for the day that
the white king becomes a snake and
starts slithering its way to munch on
some pawns sorry I really like that
action
that's unfortunate sometimes you played
a lot of Pac-Man when you were young I
didn't you no did you know snake on the
Nokia 32 days that one I did until
my snake got too long ah I managed to
really that sounded weird no no no it's
it's fine Dave David's in the same boat
he the uh
he offered her to quit early but it's
now been a pawn push in the position by
kukesh he uh I guess he had to come up
with something but now the problem is
you can just take this Pawn off for
white and
okay he doesn't even do this I was gonna
say you push forward you move your king
you bring your Rook this Pawn is
isolated there's one weakness and that's
all that uh doodle will need okay he
didn't go for this slightly surprising
but in the current position again just
create a past Pawn if you want you can
take this Pawn First perhaps
everything for white because she's
trying to confuse his opponent but no
chance here
and uh here we go the passport has been
created that's going to tie down the
black Bishop next the white King's gonna
move out the way the white Rook is going
to come and actually the black king is
coming under
serious attack potentially
yeah it's just one side of traffic
the poor opening from kakash and he's
never fought back big blunder of course
but uh
cause uh that was caused by his opening
choice I feel so Duda is looking strong
in this tournament we haven't followed
his games you will get to that but he's
won one two three four five could be
about win six games well he just won
yeah good cash resigns yeah yeah wow
it's over after 42 moves it's a win for
you on Christoph he uh couldn't keep it
up after winning against Magnus Carlsen
very understanding